This lesson is about sorting in
a distributed memory system.
[SOUND] I know, I know.
>> Why we gotta sort all the time?
>> Sorting is worse than
oatmeal cooked with water.
[SOUND]
>> [LAUGH] Sorting is
the opposite of fun.
[LAUGH]
>> I'd rather jab myself in the eye with
a hot poker than learn yet
another sorting algorithm.
>> [SOUND]
>> Sorting gives me a rash.
>> Sorting.
>> Okay.
Are you done whining?
Sorting is really important.
Not because you're going to go through
life with people asking you to write
sorting algorithms all the time.
It's partly because it's
a fundamental primitive.
for example, every time a map reduce
computation executes somewhere,
data is being sorted.
But more importantly, you should pay
attention to the sorting lesson because
it's good practice, for learning how
to think about algorithms in general.
And since it's a core part of CS101,
I think it's really helpful for
you to see how to sort in
different computing environments.
For example, sorting sequentially,
versus sorting for
a vector parallel system, versus sorting
for a shared memory system versus,
of course, distributed memory systems.
So, please do your best and
stick with it.
I think you'll be pleased to learn some
really neat ideas, especially when you
compare them to the ideas about sorting
that you probably already know.